so all right at first i have this book
out there i'm promoting the best thing
to do is to eat your breakfast it's the
most important meal of the day
and then i flip over to this idea where
no no no that's false information don't
eat your breakfast
fast and uh now i'm flipping and
recommending eating breakfast so what's
going on so just hear me out it will
make sense because sometimes when you
hear new information
that changes the way you do things uh
for the better um you know you have to
be willing to at least
learn about it and study about it and
then maybe even try it to see if it does
work better my goal is definitely not to
be right about things it's just to be
more successful with things and
unfortunately especially in science
there are certain
scientists that just they have their
pet theories and boy they are not very
flexible in changing their viewpoints on
their theories so i think it's a good
thing so i want to share with you some
information that
may possibly change your mind about this
as well and i'm not saying you should
even do it but just hear me out you have
various variables you have your diet
okay and then you have
fasting your pattern of fasting okay
for me it's 20 hours fasting a four-hour
eating window
but you also have the timing of when
those patterns are
so when is your first meal is it going
to be
at 12 noon 3 o'clock it's going to be at
night well at first i thought it really
didn't matter too much okay i thought
maybe if you can you know go to bed at
night you wake up you're already fasting
why would you want to eat right you just
ride the wave and you go as long as you
can and that seemed to work pretty good
but there's something that happened to
me recently that caused me to just look
at this timing a little bit closer
i'd say about two weeks ago i was i ate
really late and i ate a lot of protein
and i did not sleep hardly at all
and it got me thinking first of all
protein tends to stimulate and wake the
body up and of course if you eat a lot
of that late at night that's not good
too
so i started to do some research into
this area and found this right here
early time restrictive eating
and there's
quite a bit of hardcore research on this
basically eating earlier in the day
because that
aligns with your circadian rhythms a bit
more which i found interesting
especially since it affected my sleep so
in other words the whole concept is
basically do your pattern but just
switch it earlier
and uh don't eat past like three o'clock
but i want to share with you some of the
research on this it's pretty interesting
there was better homa ir
results what's homo ir that's a test to
measure insulin resistance so basically
there was improved insulin sensitivity
okay so that's
that's cool number two there's better
blood sugars now these studies that are
listing down below
really are not changing the diet they're
not changing the pattern of eating
they're just changing the timing of when
you eat that's it
and we have better blood sugars number
three there's better or improved beta
cell response that is the main cell in
the pancreas that produces insulin and
so it just responded better which is
interesting
number four
you had less appetite
in the evening now
a lot of people graze at night
so
if you can just really handle that
appetite at night so there's absolutely
no cravings whatsoever that can be
beneficial and number five there was
better insulin levels
after
you're eating so when you eat the
insulin should spike a certain level
well there was less spiking so obviously
it was better insulin control over the
food that you ate number six there was
more autophagy and number seven i
already mentioned this it aligns with
your body rhythms a bit more apparently
in the evening
the the genes that deal with food are
more downgraded they're supposed to be
downgraded not upgraded so if you eat
too late you kind of upgrade them and
start activating them
and because it's part of your digestive
system that's going to kind of wake you
up and affect your sleep so i found that
fascinating so
my pattern is 20 hours of fasting and
for our eating window so
i will eat at 9 a.m okay
first meal second meal at one and then
i'm done i will not eat anything past
this
now another thing that this
tends to solve is this little cortisol
spike at eight o'clock in the morning
where a lot of people get this wave of
hunger and
you know always just tell people to push
through it
but if you did eat here and then had
your next meal here and maybe even go to
three o'clock and if your pattern is a
little bit different it might give you
more results with what you're trying to
achieve now the drawback is that
if there's a social event with other
family members at dinner
you know that's going to create a
problem so it does throw off your
schedule and i'm not even saying that
you should do this pattern all i'm
saying is that it's something to look at
if maybe you want to squeeze out more
results
i'm going to continue to do this for a
couple more weeks
and
so far so good but i'm not 100 sold on
this quite yet i want to do this for a
little bit longer to see what happens
but i like the concept i like the
results so far i am noticing improvement
in my sleep so i just wanted to
introduce you to this
concept
and something you may want to consider
or not depending on where you're at and
your results that you're getting and
since we're on the topic of blood sugars
i recently released a video on a really
cool spice that you can consume that can
even take you to the next level with
your blood sugar so i'm going to put
that up right here check it out